political pundants and pollsters who
predicted that Argentina's ruling
peronist party was finished misjudged
its staining
power despite overseeing crippling
triple digit inflation peronist economy
Minister Sasa scored more than 36% of
votes in the first round of bitterly
fought presidential
elections I know that many of those who
voted today are those suffering the most
but as president I will not fail you
Masa will be facing off radical
libertarian Economist Javier M an
eccentric Ultra conservative who vows to
quote make Argentina great
again his supporters took selfies with a
symbolic Chainsaw the instrument mle
vows to symbolically use to pulverize
government spending replace the
country's currency with the US dollar
and eliminate the central
bank better Argentina is possible under
liberalism so we must fight for
Freedom supporters especially those
under 30 see him as a
savior others though fear he'll thrust
Argentina back 200 years Argentina's
governing parist party has done much
better than expected yet the final
outcome of this election is still far
from predictable Argentina's next
president will ultimately be decided by
the rly 23 % of Voters who supported
neither candidate and whom in one
month's time will have to choose between
whom many call the lesser of two evils
Luc Al jaer
buenos make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer